ah j'aime beaucoup cette chaîne j'aime
beaucoup la personne euh et il y a une
info qui est certaine en voici et je
sais pas quelqu'un voulait en parler
non mais
c'est qui
c'est voici la sortie une grosse enquête
sur Denis brogni avec plusieurs de ses
anciennes collaboratrices qui sont
dans laquelle d'anciennes collaboratrice
l'accuse d'humiliation tout le monde
sait que Denis Brogniart est capable de
colère humiliante surtout envers les
femmes
il y a plusieurs collaboratrices qui se
plaignent de son attitude attention pas
sexuelle mais misogyne virile
désagréable et tout ça oui Florian oui
bon déjà voici ils y vont très très fort
parce qu'ils titres il est en une c'est
le tyran de TF1 et ils ont plusieurs
témoignages qui revient notamment sur
une journaliste au 14 juillet à qui
l'aurait particulièrement mal parlé une
autre journée sportive en plateau qu'il
aurait qu'il aurait insulté etc donc il
y a des témoignages qu'il a qu'il a pas
contredit parce qu'il témoigne et
effectivement il s'excuse auprès des
gens qui la répondu il a répondu en
revanche il souligne que ce ne sont pas
assez fait isolés qui représentent 30
ans de carrière etc moi de mon côté j'ai
passé quelques petits coups de fil à des
gens qui ont travaillé avec lui pendant
des mois voilà donc ils l'ont vu au
quotidien et qui eux n'ont jamais
assisté à ce type de d'accord
voilà donc je connais toi oui je te
connais comme comme beaucoup de gens qui
font la télé et puis très longtemps mais
le problème moi la meilleure façon de
voir si les gens sont sympas ou pas
sympa en dehors des plateaux c'est
demander aux gens qui bossent derrière
oh merde non mais enfin on passe
aujourd'hui
non mais si tu as la régie sur sur les
gens que nous sommes et tu verras que ça
se trompe pas beaucoup quoi et Denis
Brogniart tous ceux qu'on bossait avec
lui il y a peut-être quelques
contre-exemples j'en sais rien il y a
des contre-exemples c'est plutôt un mec
charmant et même en tant qu'animateur
animateur c'est toujours été un mec
assez loyal assez cordial et assez sympa
quoi voilà donc il a dit je suis très
engagé perfectionniste à l'occasion des
deux directs sur TF1 ou la pression
était intense j'ai eu des mots qui ont
dépassé compenser des propos qui ont
heurtaient certaines personnes et je
regrette pardon rien ne justifie mon
comportement qui faisait suite à
certaines difficultés c'est fait isoler
ne rentre pas compte des relations
privilégiées bla bla bla bla bref
effectivement il s'excuse et on connaît
pas sa vie à ce moment-là donc
effectivement je trouve que voici est
très dur oui un dernier mot quand on en
avait discuté l'autre fois j'avais
évoqué justement le nom de Denis
Brogniart en disant lui aussi il arrive
de piquer des colères et d'être parce
que effectivement exactement ce qu'il
dit le perfectionnisme un ananas et que
par moment on tombe mal je l'ai vu il
est des journalistes je l'ai vu
m'engueuler moi je lui ai répondu et
c'est un mec que je pense profondément
droit sauf que effectivement en plus il
bosse sur des secteurs ou il faut y
aller et donc honnêtement je trouve que
on n'est pas des exemples parfois il
m'avait d'humeur
j'arrive il me dit tiens tu es de bonne
humeur aujourd'hui sous-entendu parfois
tu es un connard bah pardon je suis
humain c'est tout le temps de bonne
humeur toi
ça veut dire que rien ne te touche dans
la vie tu n'as pas d'empathie
problème en Ukraine ou dans le monde ça
me